AHEAD AND BEGIN THE COMBAT
HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING THE
FIRST ONE OF THE YEAR- THERE WE
WILL HAVE A TIME LIMIT OF. OF
TEN MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE OF
FOR BOTH BILLS. BUT GROUP THAT
SHOULD BE. I'M SORRY SIX
MINUTES NEVER MIND WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT DOING TEN MINUTES I'M
SORRY. ADDITIONAL. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE ASKED TO
STATE THEIR NAME IN THE
ORGANIZATION FOR THE RECORD IN
THE BAND THEIR POSITION ON THE
MEASURE THERE ARE NO BILLS BY A
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT- THERE
WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL TO YOUR
BILL HEARING ON FRIDAY THE
SEVENTEENTH POND A GERMAN A
SESSION HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
TWO TO HEAR AB FOR NINETY FIVE
MURATSUCHI WHICH IS DOUBLE
REFERRED ACTUALLY BEING HEARD
TODAY AN ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC SO PRETTY TOUGH HERE
BOTH IN THE SAME IN THE SAME
DAY SO- WITH THAT- WE WILL ASK-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELENDEZ TO
COME FORWARD AND PRESENT A
BEING NINE FORTY WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM. SO WE ARE OPERATE AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE. OKAY. THERE WE
GO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
BEFORE YOU THIS AFTERNOON IS A
MEASURE THAT SEEKS TO ENSURE
PEOPLE SUFFERING FROM SUBSTANCE
ABUSE ADDICTIONS ARE NOT
TREATED LIKE CASH COWS BUT AS A
FRAGILE IN SUSCEPTIBLE
INDIVIDUALS THEY ARE IN NEED OF
CARE AB NINE FORTY PROHIBITS A
RECOVERY RESIDENTS ALSO KNOWN
AS A SOBER LIVING HOME FROM
GIVING OR RECEIVING MONEY
AUSTIN IS PATIENT BROKERING A
FOR THE ROOF THE PERSON WHO IS
SEEKING RECOVERY TREATMENT
SERVICES IF ENACTED THIS
MEASURE WILL POWER THE STATE TO
FIND PATIENT BURGER TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH
VIOLATION. CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING A SURGEON PATIENT
BROKERING OUR PARENTS ARE SOLD
ESSENTIALLY TO POORLY OPERATED
RECOVERY PROGRAMS. WE'RE
RUNNING LATE DRUGS. AREN'T
NUMEROUS OUTLETS LIKE THE NEW
YORK TIMES IN THE GUARDIAN SHOW
HOW THIS PRACTICE. HOW THIS
PRACTICE BILLS INSURANCE
COMPANIES HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THEN LEAVES HE'S
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILIES INTO DEBT.
SENATE BILL TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
FROM A FORMER SENATOR LARA.
WHICH WAS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BAND PATIENT BURKE
RING FOR MEDICALLY LICENSED
ALCOHOLISM AND DRUG ABUSE
RECOVERY TREATMENT PROGRAMS IT
DID NOT INCLUDE THESE TYPES OF-
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE SOBER
LIVING HOMES. THIS BILL JUST
PUTS- BUILDS UPON REALLY AB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT AND
PROHIBITS RECOVERY RESIDENCES
FROM PATIENT BURKE RING HAS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION AND IS
STRONGLY SUPPORTED BY THE
COUNTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS
AUSTIN IN A CCAP P. AND HERE
TESTIFIED IS SHERRY DAILY FROM
C. A. P. P. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
ARMCHAIR MEMBERS SHERRY DAILY
WITH CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM.
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS WE
REPRESENT OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
RECOVERY RESIDENCES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE WERE
CO SPONSORS OF SB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT TO PROHIBIT PATIENT
BROKERING. WE'RE ALSO SPONSORS
OF SOME OF ALL NINE NINETEEN
FROM AT CUTTING PETRIE-NORRIS
LAST YEAR WHICH WOULD STOP THE
SORTS OF PAYMENTS GOING ON
BETWEEN. AN ORGANIZATION THAT
OWNS BOTH TYPES OF ENTITIES
THIS IS THE LAST PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE TO STOP THIS DESPICABLE
BEHAVIOR IT WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WHEN THEY JUST TO WHEN
THEY DISCOVER. BOTH ENDS OF THE
BRIDE TO ACTUALLY FIND THE
OTHER END OF THE BRIDE. FOR
HOMES THAT ARE NOT ACTUALLY
OWNED BY THE TREATMENT CENTER
SO IT SIMPLY CLOSES THE LAST
LOOPHOLE- FOR THIS BEHAVIOR. I
TELL YOU MANY PARENTS AND LEFT.
CAPTION THAT I'VE TALKED TO WHO
THOUGHT THEY WON THE TREATMENT
LOTTERY AN ALL EXPENSES PAID
TRIP TO CALIFORNIA IN A PLACE
NEXT TO THE BEACH FOR THEIR
LOVED ONE TO RECOVER. TO ONLY
ARRIVE HERE AND FIND OUT THREE
DAYS LATER THAT THEY DON'T MEET
NON MEDICAL NECESSITY. AND THEN
ARE PUT OUT ON THE STREETS TO
BE HOMELESS FAR AWAY FROM HOME-
FOR THE VICTIM IS THAT TO HAVE
SUFFERED FROM THIS. AND TO
HELP. LESSEN THE IMPACT THAT.
BEHAVIOR HAS AT HOME. I WOULD
JUROR I VOTE AND THINK THIS AND
ONE FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA. WELL THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. CONNIE DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. WE NOW WANT TO
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE WE ARE
STILL AS A SUB COMMITTEE THE
BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SO- AND WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM WILL BRING IT UP
FOR A VOTE WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE-
NOTE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN-
I WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASKED
WE ARE BUT I AM APPRECIATIVE
THAT YOUR ATTENTIVENESS TO
THIS. MATTER I KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS IN THE PAST AND I THINK IT
RAY RECOGNIZES THE ISSUE AT
HAND TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
ADVANCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SEE WE STILL WERE
LIKE A QUORUM WE HAVE ONE MORE
BILL IT'S- PEPPERS BE THE
CHAIRS BILL I'M ASKED THE VICE
CHAIR IF HE WOULD MIND TAKING
OVER. THANK YOU. OR. WILL COME
SAYS THEY HAVE SOME. IT IF WE
CAN JUST FOR MOMENT BECAUSE
LET'S SAY WE YOU NOW THEY HAD
TO HAVE A QUORUM. PLEASE CALL.
ROLL WHAT HERE MAYES HERE HEY
GAR CURRY BIGELOW BONTA WORK
CARILLO. FLORA LOW MOAN.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN RAMOS YEAH
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON. WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM SO- MISTER
CHAIR DOCTOR WOULD AB NINE TEN-
YOU MAY FOR THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AB
NINE TEN WOULD REQUIRE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS IN MANAGED
CARE OF MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO SUBMIT UNRESOLVED
DISPUTES TO DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SECOND
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO ISSUE.
IT IS A DECISION WITHIN THREE
DAYS AS YOU KNOW MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS ARE FUNDED
AND ADMINISTERED SEPARATELY
IT'S IMPORTANT DISPUTE THAT
DISPUTES BETWEEN THE PLANS BE
REPORTED IN WAS IN A TINY BASIS
CARE THE LATE I WITH YOU TODAY
WE HAVE SPONSORED. FROM WELL
WESTERN CENTER I'M PART. AWAY
AND RESPECT ESCRIBIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHE IS LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY POVERTY PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE WHICH WOULD STRENGTH IN
AT EXPEDITE THE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESS WHEN A MEDI
CAL PLAN AND THE COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLAN DISAGREE ON-
PROVIDING- MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO MEDI CAL ANNUALLY
OUR LEGAL AID ADVOCATES REPORT
A LONG WAIT TIMES. A YEAR OR
LONGER FOR BOTH. AND IT ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. IN TERMS
OF ACCESSING NEEDED MEDICAL
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WHEN
PLANS DISAGREE ON WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE OF THIS BILL AS THE
CHAIR NOTES- EXPEDITES IS THIS
PROCESS AND- ENSURES THAT
INDIVIDUALS GO. WITHOUT DELAYS
IN NEEDED CARE A WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THAT HAS
NO OPPOSITION THANK YOU. GREAT
THANKS SO MUCH WILL MOVE TO
MANY WITH THE SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- I WOULD CAN DOWNEY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
PROUD TO SUPPORT AND THANK THE
CHAIRMAN FOR THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE WHITE SEEM ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL.
JESSICA RAN OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SEEING NO FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE BILL I
WE ALREADY GOT A MOTION FROM A
SUMMER RODRIGUEZ AND A SECOND
FROM A SUMMER RAMOS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
OF PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- I
GUESS THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. AND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
MAYES HI MAYES AYE AYE GREGORY
I THANK OUR CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA. BURKE BURKE
I CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA
FLORA AYE LIMóN. MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
WALDRON AYE. THE BILL PASSES
WITH A VOTE OF ELEVEN TO ZERO
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- GOING BACK
TO- A. B. NINE FORTY WHICH WE
HEARD IS OUR MOTION. MOTION BY
MISS WALDRON SECOND BY MISTER
MAYES MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY HI THERE CREE AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BONTA
BONTA AYE BURKE. BURKE I
CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA
I LIVE ALONE. MCCARTY NAZARIAN.
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON WALDRON
AYE. THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES
IS OUT- WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON- WE
HAVE MEMBERS WHO HAVEN'T
CHECKED IN WE'VE WE ARE BILLS
OR WE'RE NOT DONE WITH OUR OUR
BILL CALENDAR WOULD ASK THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE HAVE NOT COME
TO VOTE PLEASE COME AND VOTE
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THIS OPEN
FOR. THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU. HOW MISTER BONTA I'M
SORRY WOULD LIKE TO OPEN THE
ROLE ON EIGHTY NINE TEN MEMSIC
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BONTA
BONTA AYE LOW MOAN MCCARTY
NAZARIAN. THAT'S ONE ZERO THANK
YOU MISS RUN TO. IF YOU. MY.
BOB. AT NIGHT. YEAH YEAH. YEAH
SOME OF. THE MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE COME OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FOR EIGHTY
NINE TEN LIMóN. THE MON I
MCCARTY NAZARIAN. THIRTEEN ZERO
NUMBER THIRTEEN- PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR EIGHTY NINE FORTY.
LOAN MON I MCCARTY THIS AREA.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN ZERO THIS IS
A THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU. I
GUESS. THE KEYPAD LOCK.
CRITICAL THINKING YEAH SO ON
ITS OWN KIND. UNTIL SO.
QUESTION. IT'S GOING TO THIS.
HOSPITAL. HONEST TO. YEAH YEAH.
YEAH. YEAH EXACTLY WE SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FOR EIGHTY NINE
TEN MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO THANK YOU AND
THEN ALSO OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FOR A NAVY
NINE FORTY. MCCARTY. I MCCARTY
AYE IN THIS AREA. FOURTEEN
THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU CAN.
DANCING THIS IS. TO IN A
. OKAY
WE ARE- CAN I WOMEN ALSO BY THE
FINAL VOTE COUNT WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE THE HEARING. AB NINE TEN.
SUBCOMMITTEE ON A VOTE OF
FOURTEEN ZERO AB NINE FORTY.
CLOSED OUT- OR AS OUT OF
COMMITTEE ON A VOTE OF FOURTEEN
TO ZERO. THAT'S THE THAT THAT
IS OUR MEETING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. A TEENAGER